[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the
clemson quarterback trevor lawrence on
the program
uh first time that we've had uh trevor
on thanks for joining us got notre dame
coming up this weekend
the acc title game by the way what's the
weather like there in clemson
a little little cold this morning oh
don't don't say cold
now this is cold up here that's not cold
what is it like
60 degrees uh it's like it's probably
upper 40s oh it is yeah not not too bad
though
it'll warm up you know by the afternoon
it'll be 60 so
uh could you have played college
football in a cold weather climate
i wouldn't have uh i wouldn't have
preferred it but i think i think i could
have done it
but i don't know i kind of i like
playing in the cold just because we
don't do it often
but uh to do it every week from october
on would be
would be rough but uh man i i think it
would have been fine
but if you didn't go to clemson where
were you going
my other top school was probably georgia
so that's still
you know in the south it's hot down here
and staying in state as well
yep yeah um how difficult was it to
watch the notre dame game from the
sidelines
it's tough i mean as a competitor you
just want to be out there and obviously
the circumstances are just
crazy being able to be at the game but
can't play
it wasn't you know in the i guess i
wasn't
you know contagious or whatever for for
coving anymore so that was kind of
frustrating but
just the way it is part of it but yeah
it was definitely frustrating obviously
dj played really well so that you know
made it a little bit easier just that he
was ready to go
played well but wish i could have been
out there to you know
give us a chance how long did it take
you to learn how to pronounce dj's last
name
not too long someone told me you know i
thought it was ukulele at first but
someone told me pretty early so i i kind
of made it a point to get it right
well let's hear it
okay all right just just want to make
sure that you got that right
uh when you're watching film on notre
dame what jumps out at you
oh they're just i mean just a good team
all the way around really
there's no there's really not any weak
links um and then they're just really
disciplined they know what they're doing
they don't try to necessarily confuse
you obviously they have some good
third down packages and some good
disguises but they're not overly
complicated it's just
they do what they do and they do it well
they're really good in the run game
really physical
especially with their you know d-line
and linebackers
um they usually always have an extra hat
in the box something they do a really
good job of
but yeah they're just really disciplined
you know run game and pass game their
gap sound
and they know what they're doing so i
think that's the biggest thing when did
you know you were famous
i don't know i mean i come from a small
town so i guess through high school it
was
um everybody kind of knew who i was just
being from a small
football town in georgia but i think
probably
after the first national championship it
kind of went
to a new level especially around here
just going out to places just kind of
changed
so i think that's probably when i was
like things
things can't go back to how they were
you know it's it's different now
but were you prepared for it yeah i
think i uh
just my journey and it's kind of been
gradual
all that it's been building to this
point so i think i've been preparing for
it
um and then just realizing kind of what
my what my platform and role entails
and just kind of accepting it at first
it's like some things can be kind of
frustrating or whatever but then you
just realize like um you know i'm in
this situation for a reason and try to
use it for good
do you read twitter yeah i'm on twitter
i'm on twitter i try to not be on it too
much
because i think everybody knows that
there's a whole lot of
a lot of stuff out there but um i try to
i try to keep up a little bit but it can
be
definitely be distracting if you let it
if you look into it too much
but you got to have a sense of humor
though trevor oh yeah oh yeah
no it's uh some of the stuff i see is
just it's just funny but
yeah i look at it a little bit i'm not
surprised you're on it i'm surprised
you're admitting that you're on it
because it'd be one of those where maybe
you tell your
fiance hey just tell me what they're
saying just tell me the good parts of
what they're saying not the bad parts
maybe i should maybe i should start
doing that no i
i really do try to because i like to
stay uh
you know involved and kind of on social
media and just like that's a good tool
but at the same time i try to like limit
it a little bit
so i only look at it certain times this
crazy i mean the stuff that
people send me and you just get tagged
in all that stuff it's wild
did you ever meet that woman who looks
like you did you ever reach out to her
i didn't i didn't reach out but i did
meet her she came to a game last year
um she came we do our tiger walk we park
on the road and walk
that little stretch to the locker room
she was right there so of course there's
a bunch of
pictures and stuff it's crazy but but
did you think
kind of she looks like me i i did i was
like
i don't obviously don't like to admit
that but i was like that's pretty that's
pretty close
how important is the heisman i mean it's
i've said it before it's like that's a
hard question i mean it's obviously
something that would be awesome to win
and i'm not going to say that it
wouldn't be and i wouldn't you know
love that that would be great but
honestly i mean and that's the truth i
just don't really focus on it too much i
think
that's an award that um your play speaks
for itself and there's a lot of factors
that go into it and especially
a season like this where everyone's
played different games schedule's been
kind of rearranged blown up all those
things it's just a tough thing to gauge
so i don't put too much stake in it you
know i know who i am
confident who i am regardless of whether
i win it or not but obviously
i you know i i don't have to say that it
would be a huge accomplishment to be
able to
be considered for to win it yeah but
there's nothing wrong with saying
i want it yeah i mean it's i mean
obviously
um when you're competitive and you and
you play
a sport like college football um
you put a lot of time in a lot of work
so the awards all that stuff is is
really cool and it you know you kind of
get recognized for
the work you put in so that i mean that
would be awesome but if i'm having
to pick between that and national
championship no no hesitation from me
so i don't know maybe those will go hand
in hand that'd be awesome too
it'll be notre dame and clemson in the
acc championship game this saturday at 4
eastern we're talking to
trevor lawrence when's the last time you
got yelled at by dabo
um probably
the miami game actually got yelled at
you know he's kind of got onto me a few
times but
uh he chewed me out pretty good after
miami game scored a touchdown
spiked the ball got a flag
he kind of ripped into me there so that
was the first time in a while so
that's what he said after the game he's
like i don't give any chances to
trevor out so i'm gonna take it when i
get it
i didn't know if you start laughing or
you want to laugh because
you know that he doesn't really mean it
but when he starts yelling at you is
there any part of you that just wants to
go
no coach stop don't no i think it's
it's just like that relationship where
me i mean me and coach sweeney have a
great relationship but just
it's one of those things where you got
to he's got to make sure he takes his
opportunities to get onto me when he can
just to show that nobody's bigger than
anybody else that's like that's
it's just you know it's all part of it i
respect him but it's funny the other
guys in the team kind of laughing about
it coming up to me after because it
doesn't happen much some of those other
guys get chewed out all the time
do you do an imitation of coach
uh not really we have some guys that
that do
a really good one i haven't really i
ain't got it down yet
well does he have a saying or a look
that these guys try to imitate
i mean i just it's just funny how
internally
the stuff he does to motivate us and the
stuff he says is just
it's just there's too many to to name i
mean he has so many sayings we call him
sweeney-isms that he just says all the
time
it's like beat into our brain so he's he
does a good job of making sure we leave
here
with some quotes do you grow up an nfl
fan
not really honest i grew up watching
college football mostly didn't watch the
nfl too much
um obviously just a big football fan but
yeah i was more of a college football
fan
growing up do you have posters growing
up did you wear
nfl jerseys anything like that
oh not really i think i i think i might
have when i was a little kid like a
peyton manning jersey from
from the colts but like i said i really
wasn't i mean he was my favorite player
better than that i didn't really
watch it too much or have a favorite
team have you met him
i did i met him uh i guess the first
time i met him was
two summers ago at the hit their camp
the manning camp so
it was cool their whole family is good
people so it was good
when's the last time you watched an nfl
game
i actually just wat i watched the la the
very end of the game last night the
uh browns and ravens i caught like the i
saw that it was like going back and
forth so i turned it on
but honestly i don't watch too much or
we're either in practice or
um getting home late or whatever so i
don't really watch so much but i keep up
with it you know
by keeping up with who's doing well and
obviously the i think it was
like the steelers when they were
undefeated i always kind of like
root for those teams it would be cool to
see them finish that
obviously they're still still playing
well but um so stuff like that i kind of
keep up with
but how can you not
let the situation with the jets affect
you or at least
you know that you could end up in new
york if they don't win and you're the
number one pick
you don't get to pick where you want to
go and that's really difficult for
you know somebody just starting out but
how prepared are you
to do something like that
i mean i think i'm i think i'm ready um
i think just being here at clemson my
journey is
has taught me a lot i've grown up a lot
the past few years and
i'm really just ready to take on
whatever challenge it is um
and just have opportunity have you
watched the jets trevor
i haven't really honestly i'll be
obviously don't don't
highlights and stuff don't no i mean
really
like honestly i know some of this stuff
i say sounds cliche but just to
have the opportunity to go somewhere
help someone rebuild if that's what it
is or whatever and just win
that's what you know something i love
doing i think that's what i'm best at
is winning you know regardless of stats
whatever it is that's that's what i love
so
just to have that chance obviously some
places it'll be more of a challenge than
others but
um i think i think i'm up for it and
that that that'll get here
when it's here just trying to focus now
on on being great where i'm at
you're officially leaving clemson right
after the final four
i mean it's it's likely obviously i'm
not i don't want to completely shut any
door
but uh well didn't they introduce you on
senior day so that i thought that might
have been
their way of saying that yeah so i'm
graduating so
coach sweeney let me go ahead hey but
christian wilkins he he did it twice he
ran down the hill twice
two years in a row so you never know
how far do you think you could throw it
right now on that practice field
um if you warmed up if you warmed up
i would say probably like 65 to maybe
it's between 65 and 70. i don't i don't
i can't necessarily throw it the
farthest but
uh far far enough i'll say that well
hopefully you don't have to throw it
that far but yeah it's always i was
curious
can dj throw it farther than you oh yeah
he's got a cannon
he's a big guy he's as big as any
defensive player you go up against
didn't he
yeah he's about 250 probably six five
250.
he's huge that's crazy uh
i've had to try to put weight on he's
trying to keep it off we got opposite
problems and we can just
kind of meet in the middle well college
football should be proud that they've
had you for three years and uh the nfl
will be proud to have you as well uh you
have done some great things there and
you get an opportunity to hopefully play
in the the final four there
and uh we wish you luck against notre
dame and uh we were glad to have you on
trevor
yeah thank you dan thanks for having me
appreciate you guys
i took a while to get him but uh good
appearance by trevor lawrence very
likable
yeah yes